So, to recap, we see that humans begin to speak around the same time and follow
predictable patterns of language development. We've seen the importance of
nature, meaning the language areas of our brain, so the Wernicke's area and the
Broca's area, and nurture, meaning our exposure to models who imitate our
language and reinforce our language. We saw that the amount of words a child is
exposed to, is a function of nurture. Psychologists have different theories
regarding language acquisition and there continues to be discussion regarding
these theories. And finally we saw that other species can be taught to use
American sign language and use it to communicate not only with humans but each
other as well. Okay, so now let's move onto thought.